yeah welcome to the Sun blitz video
playing go from France Cantor Kings
gambit don't see that too often playing
on sideline here he's playing 93 m I
actually forgot the three reams so let's
hope I'm not too severely punished for
that yeah I tend to play d5 I wanted to
prevent 95 first with this X
hmm yeah this is certainly not the best
way for black to play but it still seems
like it should lead to a rather normal
position if I castle now our key can't
play 92 but then I have at least d5 yeah
if your move Bishop before and not take
one c3 this move looks a bit silly 92
but I had a mad d5 at least until not
too bad okay let's a get pieces out here
texty father takes c3 first then d5 to
gain the temple now okay you can get the
Pont back now taking on auto and g6 I
can even take with the airport not even
regaining the pawn it does it anyway
strangely enough
yeah yeah g5 may be at so many ways to
get a good position but this looks fine
keeping the polar form therefore point
is rather irritating provide i also have
Bishop to your form so maybe this first
so should I cover the apron yeah maybe
it's not because of the poem but it's
useful anyway Bishop b4 Quincy forms of
course the idea it also prepares work to
c 6 which she ignores okay it's not
terrible threat but ok put this the only
form
yeah the supported pawn on f4 is quite a
nuisance
hmm yeah maybe this is there there are
many many ideas this intense g4 f3
yeah this is very slow they cannot play
g3 even F to enter resigns so let's
think for a moment
yeah what's what's the best hearing I
really shouldn't look for any any need
to need to get a mate in here already
yeah still this Queen h3 and route g6g
to look so looks deadly ready oh gee too
hard to see how I prevent that Queen f1
on Sarabjit oh and there's no defense
yeah I don't I think this is the capture
on g6 followed by 95 is really leading
to to some trouble maybe the computer
can can keep this kind of position
together but it's not looking nice now I
hoped you two it's over there's simply
no defense and any move basically this
and made on h2 snow no way to defend it
Thank um maybe he didn't really think
about FTX g6 if you see ft sg6 you
pretty much cannot take on g6 here
probably some normal move queen bee
three may be preparing c3 and then Queen
back or so this should be quite okay for
white I mean I'm a pawn up with black
but it's it's nothing nothing terribly
great but after taking him I get this g5
and Bishop three for this is really a
problem this is one one issue actually
with the Kings committed it weakens your
central squares sometimes leads to this
kind of positions yeah i wrote yet it's
already very tricky i guess to defend
computer wants to go f3 yets already
winning directly but this is also very
tough to defend yeah you cannot allow
that getting the bishop only for he
cannot you shouldn't take here just um
let's turn quickly just just this for
example something along these lines this
should be okay Black is fine
it's probably just just evil yeah thanks
for watching